see not winging it isn't really what
they do what exactly is it that they do
kick names hey guys hey everybody its
charlie I wanted to make a video about
guardians of the galaxy three Avengers
four in the future of Marvel phase four
given what just happened to James Gunn
because it was really big news over the
weekend so big that it didn't get buried
by all the other comic-con trailers and
news that was dropping so if you're
brand new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the Marvel videos
I'm doing a new round of that infinity
war blu-ray giveaway I'll explain at the
end of the video what happened was is
that Friday James Gunn was formally
fired by Disney as the director of
guardians of the galaxy three he was
also an executive producer on Avengers 4
and he was in the process of helping
them develop the next 10 years worth of
Marvel space based movies Kevin Feige
had referred to that as the Marvel
cosmic universe so guardians 3 was
probably going to be James Gunn's the
last Marvel movie that he would direct
and he would just help them produce
whatever future space space movies they
did like if they did a rocket and Groot
spin-off movie there's the Nova movie
that they were talking about there's all
the x-men space based movies that
they'll be able to do after the Fox
Disney deal closes next year Kevin Feige
is boss was the one that actually did
the firing he gave this statement about
why they were firing him so what
happened is is that James Gunn was the
target of an attack by a blogger that
dug up all the worst possible jokes that
you could imagine that he had made on
Twitter that were from between 9 and 7
years ago it was before Disney hired him
to develop guardians of the galaxy write
the script direct the movie so it was
before his relationship with Disney I'm
not gonna put any of the tweets in here
but James Gunn was trying to be funny in
the most edge Lord way possible when he
was initially hired by Disney they did
vet and look at all his tweets they
still chose to hire him he apologized
for making all these really
inappropriate jokes but you have to
understand that they were really really
bad but all that stuff getting drug back
up in present day with the current state
of the internet just freaked Disney out
so you have to imagine that they're a
very family branded company they like to
present themselves as being very morally
virtuous so when Billy
dollars are on the line Disney hits the
panic button and their decision was to
fire James gun that happened within
about 12 hours of drama going down it
started like Thursday night by Friday
morning they'd announce that they'd
fired him so basically he got fired for
making a bunch of really really
inappropriate jokes 7 to 9 years ago
most of the main actors and a bunch of
people have come to his defense saying
that you know like he apologized for
this a long time ago he said that he was
trying to be an edge lord none of this
stuff is true it was just him trying to
get a reaction out of people so no one
is trying to condone what he did James
Gunn isn't trying to condone it either
he's not trying to say that he wasn't
guilty of saying all those things he has
a big movement of people that are trying
to get Disney to rehire him I don't
think they're gonna rehire him but the
good news is is that he had already
turned in the finished script for
guardians 3 they were getting ready to
shoot in January like it was getting
ready to come up they're gonna start
promoting Captain Marvel they were
getting ready to drop the Avengers 4
trailer so it's a really critical
business period for Disney right now
heading into Avengers 4 and all these
big movies next year Disney didn't want
to have a bigger situation on their
hands so that's what's happened it's a
bit of a developing situation they
haven't announced a new director that's
gonna come on the good news is though is
that even if they hire a glorified
traffic cop to execute James Gunn's
vision it'll probably still wind up
being a good movie and Gunn and foggy
had already had some of the big ideas
for the next 10 years so like there's
already a template for these other
space-based movies they're gonna be
developing it's just that we would lose
James Gunn's voice in any of his
creative because even though he doesn't
direct all the Marvel movies he does
offer a lot of creative oversight when
they're doing certain things like just
creatively he understands the comics and
he's one of the best directors in
Hollywood right now music is such an
important part of this movie and that's
a soundtrack and the score I think in
this movie particularly the score is
absolutely wonderful
and something we do is we write the
score first so Tyler writes big pieces
of the score to the script and then I
use those pieces of score on set to play
while we're shooting well playback
[Music]
sometimes it allows an actor to go
further be broader more intense dude
it's in my head the music is in my head
when you have a song that fits the tone
of what's really going on between these
two characters that are having a moment
with each other you take see they're
like so quickly and it moves you it
allows you to just step out of the way
of the music and let the music take the
lead
[Music]
we're shooting the emotional ending in
my headphones in an earbud with in
Chris's ear in an earbud with the
Rooker's ear we hear the music that
Tyler Bates played for this moment and
it made it an emotional experience on
set because there's so much emotion in
that music saving grace is the Kevin
Feige does have an eye for talent he
just brought in Ryan Coogler just
totally hit it out of the park with
Black Panther that movie was totally
Ryan Coogler vision so if he can find
people like that to do these other films
then we'll still have really awesome
space based films whatever they might
end up being because they still got a
roll camera on guardians 3 around
January that means that they need to
find a new director by December if they
don't do that there's always the
possibility is delayed by a month or two
till they find the right person but the
most important pieces are all in place
this was gonna be the last film with
this roster so most of these actors were
just crossing the finish line anyway so
they're like right there on the last lap
somebody just needs to push the cart
over the finish line so any director
could probably do that but by far the
fan favorite to replace him is Taika
Waititi who currently is finishing
filming a much smaller project but he's
not booked on any other big movies
meaning that he would be available the
beauty being that he is an amazing
director that can do action comedy the
tone of thor ragnarok is very much the
same tone as the guardians films
welcome to thor ragnarok
[Music]
I guess humor it's so particular and
unique and quirky all of these tiny
little things hanging washing on
electrical cables that's exactly what we
do on earth
I'm into the story it Samoset working
with tyka involves high jinks dancing
day is just a big kid so what might be a
little bit different but it's almost a
seamless transition so I do hope that
they're able to get him but if they
don't get him then Nicole Perlman was
the person who originally developed
guardians of the galaxy before James
Gunn came on right now she's working on
the Black Widow movie but she could
always step in and direct they do have a
stable of talent that they could pick
from and most of this would be with
Kevin Feige 'he's watchful I like he
would probably step in and take a more
active role in shepherding the film to
maintain the creative vision it's very
unfortunate circumstances Marvel hasn't
said anything since they announced that
he had been fired but they're doing the
infinity war blu-ray release the digital
release in the next week so there will
be a lot of Marvel stuff happening we
might hear more later this year about
who they've found to replace him or if
they're gonna hire him back or what's
going to happen next but as for right
now I wouldn't expect much more from
Disney on this matter for at least the
next month or two till things quiet down
then they'll probably start talking
about it again there is a new round of
that infinity war blu-ray giveaway all
you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on the
video click here for more new Avengers 4
and click here to rewatch all the big
comic-con trailers thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight
[Music]